broncos three turnovers have now lost
two of their last three the chiefs like
we've talked about their defense has
been strong have allowed 11.2 points per
game during their five-game winning
streak right now one game up on the
chargers now in the afc west we've got
guys on the ground they're in chile
kansas city with jackets and scarves i
hope they're called everything i hope
you guys are freezing your butts off
it's nice and warm in here let me let me
just say this chris
hey thanks for joining the winning squad
his first game-winning pick since
september i have been tracking it the
first
september it's a beautiful day for you
chris why don't you celebrate
listen this is five wins in a row now
for kansas city and something blew
directly in my right eye i'm going one
eye as i fly this show right now
when you look at this game tonight rod
you go through this entire game i'm
going back to that final drive right
before halftime they go 20 plays do the
broncos and end up with nothing what
impact did that have on this let me tell
you something that's devastating that's
devastating to offense you go 20 plays
you wear a defense down a defense is
trying to do everything they possibly
can do to stop you and you walk away
with no points that's why i was so
frustrated when they went for it on
fourth down kick the field goal 20 point
20 plays and now you score points you
gotta always anytime you get this
opportunity to score points in a cold
game like this you have to take the
points it was a drive it started all the
way back to the three yard line they
came all the way down the field get
absolutely nothing with it how about
with patrick mahomes when you watch him
play tonight what do you need to see
more of from him well it starts with
they need more discipline he needs more
discipline and that's up to andy reid
andy reed needs to focus on his footwork
a lot of the fun fundamentals and tell
him don't worry about throwing the ball
side arm or side just focus on doing
things fundamentally sound just like
chris sams was talking about and chris i
got to tell you i could barely walk in
this win i can't i couldn't even throw
the ball to that 10 yard marker right
there what'd you see from patrick
mahomes trying to throw it through this
stuff tonight well i i think you know
rodney hit on a lot of the right points
you know again just i want to see more
consistency from patrick mahomes in the
passing offense you know still for a guy
as talented as he is you know yes we've
become accustomed to hitting the sidearm
throw and making it happen but he's not
the machine he was in your past hey
here's here's one that's great i mean
come on nobody does that better than
patrick mahomes running left throw him
back right but it's these plays again
hey that's pretty good but i'd like to
see tyree kill catch the ball running
they would've got an extra 5-10 yards
it's off just a little bit and then
plays like this where the receiver can't
even get a hand on the football or you
got travis kelsey open on a wide out
tight end out route throws it at his
feet that's what i'm not accustomed to
seeing rodney hit it right feet are all
over the place at times lets his arm get
too loose doesn't get his body in the
right positions to be the machine
throwing the football like we've seen
him be or like a brady or an aaron
rodgers how they can be
yeah and chris this is going to go down
as a kansas city blowout right but
something still looks a little bit weird
about this kansas city offense what do
you think it is watching them play and
and chris maybe you'll agree with me but
i think what they're missing is that
third guy in the passing game yeah you
know you have hill you have kelsey and
those guys can make plays but they're
really missing that third guy demarcus
robinson they tried to give him an
opportunity he hasn't really taken
advantage of it talk about byron pringle
he had two drops he's not taking
advantage of it clyde edward tulare he's
back they're trying to get him involved
but they need that third weapon in the
passing game your thoughts chris
agree i mean especially when you're when
you're a team built through the offense
right sorry to cut you off there jack
but i think that's a real thing there's
no doubt about it you know team built
through the offense they want to score
points put pressure on you that way but
rodney you know the great offenses you
defend in your career like the
indianapolis colts they had more than
two guys right it was reggie wayne
marvin harrison and edgar and james and
dallas clark you go back to like the the
greatest show on turf the rams you know
isaac bruce tory holt and marshall
fought i think it's a very real point
you bring up it's easy to take two
people out of a game plan it's that
third one that can put an offense over
the top and rodney i think you're kind
of on to something there that and i'd
like to see where's the speed sweeps the
reverses wide receiver screen game that
is another thing i would like to see
from kansas city bring some defenses up
so then we can go down the ball right
you get you you can now be creative and
throw the ball down the field what we're
accustomed to seeing from them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports